- You are literally
my number one.
I don't know if I
should even say that.
- Oh.
(laughs)
- We're out of time.
- Lame.
- It goes so quick.
- Oh my god.
- I guess I'll
see you next time.
- When will that be anyway?
- Say what?
(laughing)
- Say put your
number in my phone.
- Say what?
(theme music)
- Oh my god,
your story was so dope
yesterday on Snapchat.
I was loving it.
- Thank you.
- And you and I, we
got that fire going on.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I love it, I love it.
- You're the only
person I have that with.
(chuckles)
- That's cool.
- I feel like maybe you're a
little nervous or something.
(laughs)
- Nervous?
No, I'm not nervous.
Trust me, I go on first
dates all the time.
- So you guys ever have
any weird celeb run ins?
(chuckles)
The time when Decker saw
Clark Gregg in the hotel gym.
- Holy shit.
(exhaling)
Hey, Clark.
Clark.
Agent Clark.
(screaming)
- Wait, wait.
Kevin's story
definitely beats mine.
- Anthony, thanks for
sharing your workout with us.
- Thanks a lot.
- [Voiceover] Gonna wrap, cut.
(beep)
- Can I talk to you
over here for a minute?
- Yeah, sure bud.
What's up?
- Hey, listen.
I didn't want to do this
in front of everyone.
You remember--
- Let's keep this cool.
- Dude, come here.
You remember poker
the other night?
You owe me my $12,000.
Now don't make me fuck you up.
- Can we talk about this--
- No, let's talk about it now.
- Get the...
(groans)
Hey guys, let's wrap this up.
- [Kevin] Complete
misunderstanding.
(chuckling)
- Hey Brittany, what about you?
- I've literally never
embarrassed myself.
Oh, hey Ash.
What are you doing?
- Oh, just reading
a script for this--
- Oh my god, is it the
new Hunger Games script?
You can tell me, I
won't tell anyone.
- I think you're
thinking of Twilight.
- No, Twilight where you
had the bow and arrows.
- I was in Twilight.
Kristin Stewart plays Bella.
- [Brittany] Yes.
- The vampire falls
in love with her.
- And they eat the
poison berries, and--
- No.
- Break the sequence.
- No, okay.
- Ash can get weirdly pushy.
(gasps)
OMG, you guys.
- Oh no.
- What?
- Jesus, it's them.
- It's all of them.
- Hey buddy.
- I had no idea that little
mannequin could even eat.
I'm gonna go say hi.
- Hey.
- There she is.
- Sometimes coincidences
are so awesome.
- It's my best friend
and my arch nemesis.
- You have so many arch nemeses.
- It's better than none.
- Do not tell me you
two are on a date.
- Well--
- No, actually.
Nope, we're not, so just...
- Well actually we
were just on a date.
Until you just decided
to be a dickhole.
- Oh, you tell him Bella.
And frankly, I'm
surprised he even
has it in him to ask a lady out.
(laughing)
Seriously, I'm not here.
Please continue.
Or we just make this a
nice romantic three way.
- Never gets old, Kevin.
- [Kevin] That's right.
- Oh my god.
- Seriously?
- It's Brittany, bitch.
(chuckles)
My favorite people.
- Oh my god, this is gonna get
more violent than a
Fast and Furious sequel.
- This is not cool, man.
We should just leave.
I do not want to watch this.
- Just enjoy the ride.
- Bella, it's so good to see you
with my friend Christopher.
- Hi, how was the
whole hospital thing?
- Oh, well.
I'm proud to say I've fully
recovered after my meltdown
when you stole those three
endorsements from me.
- Oh.
- Whatever, was gonna put
a down payment on a condo.
Had to let that one go.
No big deal.
- Oh my god, you know
what Bella's perfect for?
- No.
- The Glanthor saga adaptation.
- Decker, no.
- Just picture her with
six wings and a horn.
That is the ice queen Verasia.
- Why would I be
threatened by you?
You're an 18 year old with six
million Instagram followers.
(coughs)
- Ten.
26 cross platform if we're
talking real numbers.
- Counting is tough
for you anyway.
But that's a lot.
- [Bella] It's
awkward, actually.
- Yeah, hate myself.
- Come on, don't do this.
- It's already happening.
- No, no.
- You know, this whole thing.
You guys are really
killing my vibe here.
- [Christopher] They
should leave, right?
- You guys should
stay, I'm gonna go.
- Bella.
(gasps)
It's me.
- [Bella] It's you.
Are you friends with these guys?
- [Decker] Best friends.
- Oh, well.
- Hey, I was wondering if I
could run an idea past you.
- I'm not threatened
by you at all.
(crosstalk)
(claps)
- I'm hip hopping
out of this orgy.
Cause you guys
are fucking weird.
- [Kevin] No, we should
just make it a foursome.
You're a dick slit.
You're a Zach
Galifianakis wannabe.
You're just an alcoholic.
And who the fuck are you?
You're paying for this.
Taking this with me.
- But Bella.
My laugh, remember
you like my laugh?
I thought.
- You're not getting
laid tonight.
(theme music)